es ist der startschuss für den
kommerziellen weltraumtourismus ein
kurzausflug mit voller besatzung stärke
und der chef von virgin galactic richard
branson höchstpersönlich mit an bord
gestern am sonntag dem 11 17 20 21 war
es soweit und der milliardär war
erfolgreich in den weltraum gestartet
und das vor amazon gründer jeff besser
doch es gibt einen haken und einen
rekord klicks und 20 user lebens dreimal
pro woche spannendes heinz videos
aktiviert die glocke und abonniert den
kanal nennen nur so verpasst ihr nichts
los geht's herzlich willkommen und
willkommen zum beginn eines neuen
weltraum zeitalters so twitterte richard
branson milliardär und chef der us
amerikanischen weltraum firma virgin
galactic es kurz nach seinem
weltraumabenteuer am sonntag den 11 720
121 der weltraum gehört allen der traum
von der reise ins all wird so endlich
realität mehr menschen sollte es möglich
sein astronaut oder astronauten zu
werden das alles sind die aussagen und
vision von richard branson die jetzt
schon bald realität werden könnten
zahlreiche touristinnen und touristen
aus aller welt könnten demnach also
schon bald einen kurz trip ins weltall
starten fest steht jedenfalls der erste
weltraumtourist flug mit voller
besatzung des unternehmens virgin
galactic war ein voller erfolg und der
firma mit gründer richard branson
höchstpersönlich war mit an bord und hat
damit nicht weniger als sein eigenes
leben riskiert an bord insgesamt fünf
besatzungsmitglieder
neben ihm diese tests mission mit der
bezeichnung unity 22 hat er das große
ziel erstmals einen touristischen
weltraum ausflug mit voller besatzung
stärke zu simulieren schon bald sollen
dann hier vier richtige passagiere platz
finden die für ihren kurztrip ins all
sehr viel geld zahlen in einem video
dass kurz vor dem start auf twitter
gepostet wurde sagt richard branson
meine mission ist es den traum von
weltraumreisen wahr zu machen für meine
enkelkinder für eure enkelkinder für
jeden es ist nicht weniger als ein super
rennen der milliardär mit am start tesla
chef elon musk amazon gründer jeff bezos
und der britische unternehmer richard
sie alle haben das große ziel sie wollen
den weltraum erobern so hoch so schnell
und so günstig wie möglich hat richard
branson mit dem erfolgreichen testflug
am sonntag also endgültig das rennen
gemacht verbringen wir bald schon
unseren urlaub im all
was bedeuten die aktuellen entwicklungen
für die private raumfahrt eigentlich
sollte der staat schon um 1430
mitteleuropäischer zeit stattfinden
doch ein heftiges unwetter machte
branson und seinem team einen strich
durch die rechnung wichtige geräte waren
noch im hangar und konnten so nicht
rechtzeitig zum start herbeigeschafft
werden
fast hätte also ein gewitter seinen
lebenstraum gefährdet ein riesiger
lebenstraum wie er selbst einmal auf
einem blog geschrieben hatte als kind
wollte ich ins weltall
während dies in meiner generation nicht
sehr wahrscheinlich erschien ließ sich
den namen virgin galactic eintragen mit
der vorstellung ein unternehmen zu
schaffen dass dies möglich machen würde
es ist fantastisch wohin dich eine idee
führen kann egal wie weit hergeholt sie
zunächst wirken mag das wetter führte
dazu dass das große zittern los ging
doch dann ging es doch los und zwar vom
weltraumbahnhofs spaceport america im us
bundesstaat new mexico grenzen hatte ihn
extra für dieses projekt bauen lassen
ein trägerflugzeug hatte das raumschiff
auf 14 kilometer höhe gebracht von dort
sollte dann der start in den weltraum
beginnen das raumflugzeug wurde
abgesetzt und hatte dann aus eigenem
antrieb auf mehr als die 3 fache
schallgeschwindigkeit beschleunigt mehr
als 3500 kilometer pro stunde auf den
bildern war zu sehen wie sich der himmel
von blau langsam zu schwarz gefärbt
hatte branson und sein team hatten die
atmosphäre verlassen mehr als 80
kilometern höhe
dann ein paar momente der
schwerelosigkeit so der plan und der
plan ging tatsächlich auf mehr menschen
als je zuvor befanden sich zu diesem
zeitpunkt im weltraum so hat es der
astrophysiker jonathan mcdowell
getwittert 16 personen insgesamt
inklusive der sechs personen an bord des
virgin galactic raum flugzeugs hinzu
kommen noch sieben personen an bord der
iss und drei an bord der chinesischen
raumstation
nach etwa 90 minuten war die crew um
richard branson sicher wieder in new
mexiko gelandet eine wirklich spannende
sache und ein echter pr coup
doch auch wenn das ganze jetzt so easy
klingt das ganze projekt ja ist wirklich
risikoreich dem brems und verlässt sich
auf eine technik die wenig erprobt ist
es ist nicht so krass formuliert wenn
man sagt dass er damit sein eigenes
leben und das der crewmitglieder aufs
spiel gesetzt hat eigentlich wollte der
milliardär auch erst im kommenden jahr
2022 staaten
doch der wunsch danach erster zu sein
der schien größer gewesen zu sein vor
allem der wiedereintritt in die
erdatmosphäre gilt als kritisch denn das
raumschiff stürzt achtung im freien fall
auf die erde und wird dann erst in 20
bis 30 kilometern höhe von der luft
gebremst tragisch weil im testlauf kam
dabei ein pilot ums leben und das war
nicht der einzige rückschlag für virgin
galactic das unternehmen galt lange zeit
als weit abgeschlagen vor sieben jahr
2014 war sein
spaceshiptwo über kalifornien abgestürzt
im dezember des vergangenen jahres 2020
hatte der raketenantrieb bei einem
probelauf nicht funktioniert und erst im
mai 2021 war dann der erste bemannte
testflug mit dem weltraum flugzeug wie
ss unity gelungen
richard branson selbst hatte es immer
wieder betont dass er sich selbst keine
sorgen macht ein echter abenteurer der
als kitesurfer bereits den ärmelkanal
überquert hatte und den versuch
gestartet hatte mit einem heißluftballon
die erde zu umrunden abstreiten kann
niemand das ist bei dem ziel weltraum
tourismus für alle um das große geld
geht grenzen hat sie selbst erzählt dass
ich bereits 600 menschen für einen flug
ins all angemeldet hätten und dass man
deswegen die buchung stoppen musste der
ticketpreis nicht ohne 250.000 us dollar
umgerechnet also rund 210.000 euro
ein urlaub zum schnupperpreis ja sieht
anders aus
doch das interesse ist offensichtlich da
der amazon gründer jeff bezos will am 20
juli diesen jahres 2021 nach china hat
ein anonymer bieter sogar 28 millionen
us-dollar bezahlt um beim flug dabei zu
sein
in den kommenden jahren wird sich das
wohl sicherlich nicht ändern so hatte
eine schweizer bank prognostiziert das
reisen in den weltraum bis zum jahr 2030
einen markt im umfang von drei
milliarden us dollar darstellen könnten
laut branson selbst aber gibt es kein
space race
das hat er so in einer us-talkshow
versichert ich weiß keiner wird es mir
glauben aber es gibt keinen wettbewerb
womit er einen wettstreit um die kunden
meint denn das angebot ist knapp
schon in wenigen tagen geht es weiter
und chef besser es wird sich mit einer
raumkapsel seines unternehmens blue
origin ebenfalls ins all schießen lassen
und zwar am 20 juli also genau am 52
jahrestag der ersten mondlandung von
apollo 11 ihm war richard branson mit
seinem flug am sonntag also kurzfristig
zuvorgekommen
laut branson allerdings nur ein zitat
unglaublicher wunderbarer zufall dass
beide im selben monat ins all wollen
besser setzt allerdings eine ganz andere
technik ein die herkömmliche
raketentechnologie schon 15 testflüge
waren erfolgreich verlaufen allesamt
allerdings ohne besatzung an bord der
kurz trip ins all mit der new shepherd
macht seinem namen alle ehre insgesamt
elf minuten soll er dauern und dabei
eine höhe von 100 kilometern erreichen
auch hier fliegt der boss selbst mit mit
dabei wohl auch sein bruder eine ex
piloten im stolzen alter von 82 jahren
und eine bislang noch unbekannte person
als dritter mit dem bundes also bei
diesen nicht existenten space race und
auch er mit ähnlichem visionen testchef
innenmaß mit dem richard branson noch am
morgen des staats ein foto und postet
hatte dazu grenzen
ein großer tag liegt vor uns toll um den
morgen mit einem freund zu beginnen ich
fühle mich gut aufgeregt bereit einen
mast plant ebenfalls für das laufende
jahr einen tourismus zug ins all in zwei
jahren will er mit seiner firma space
text an den mond an steuern allerdings
ist mast sein leben offenbar zu lieb er
bleibt am boden und wird nicht selbst
mitfliegen
die große frage die sicherlich noch
wellen schlagen wird war richard branson
überhaupt wirklich im weltall
denn international gilt tatsächlich die
sogenannte kammern linie in etwa 100
kilometern höhe als grenze zum weltall
die us luftfahrtbehörde faa dagegen
sieht die 80 kilometer marke als
entscheidend schon vor bransons start
hatte das unternehmen bereits von jeff
bezos darauf hingewiesen dass die
eigenen flüge über die kammern linie
hinausgehen dazu hieß es bei twitter die
new shepherd wurde von anfang an so
konzipiert dass die oberhalb der kammern
linie fliegt damit
einer unserer astronauten ein sternchen
neben seinem namen hat für 600 der
weltbevölkerung beginnt der weltraum in
100 kilometern höhe an der international
anerkannten karmann linie richard
branson lässt sich so oder so nicht
beirren schon im nächsten jahr 2022
sollen dann auch touristen touristen mit
seinem unternehmen ja nach oben fliegen
mehr zum aufbruch ins weltall der vater
in meinem buch per aufzug in den
weltraum hier mit vielen spannenden
zukunftsentwicklungen die aber schneller
kommen werden als viele vermuten das
buch gibt es in jeder guten buchhandlung
oder hier einfach draufklicken und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran